I had forgot there's like these these
three things that are just instantly
Texas summer and it's humidity no it's
cicadas uh fireflies and BlueBell ice
cream and then the fireflies I was like
man I had forgotten about fire but me of
all people forgot about fireflies well
you have a you have a difficult
relationship with fireflies I do it was
so conflicted funny enough the whole
family's from the South Arkansas also
had the cicadas and the fireflies but I
remember catching one and putting it in
a jar and then trying to basically see
if it would light up right in front of
me which of course I'm pretty sure it
immediately died but I was sitting there
holding it like any moment anymore for
like the for like the day and a half
ride back I don't think I've ever seen
one hearing you talk about it I think
it's one of those things I saw my first
hummingbirds a few weeks ago I was same
with fireflies I don't think I've ever
seen a firefly fireflies same thing it's
a very interesting seeing experiment
because what we would do is we would get
a big mason jar punch holes in the top
of it I probably didn't punch the holes
in there that's that's good but I went
in there if you listen to take one thing
from this episode oxygen is good it's a
good thing yeah